allais-je avec tout ce soir c'est la
première invitée de l'histoire à passer
[Applaudissements]
gérard gérard sabut qu'il a dominé le
tabouret oui je sais pas comment je suis
content de te voir je t'aime tellement
mais vraiment je suis comme un fou un
jour tu m'avais invité chez toi ben oui
c'est un de mes plus beaux souvenirs de
toute ma vie non j'étais là je me suis
dit je vais venir c'est toi bah voilà
bon alors il ta voix tu t'es bien des
cas là pourquoi tu as choisi pour
peut-être pas voulu venir me voir moi je
voulais que tu viens de voir est
acceptée c'est à descendre à est allé
alexandra et elle était plus qu il te
avec 105 les invités tous fake
merci exactement pareil car il pouvait
le toucher avec qui je travaille bien et
ça dit cyril avait envie que l'on fêtait
en fait j'étais à l'écart d'un rabat
comment s'appelle ce marquis de sade
ouais puis à l'acoss voilà près donc
tarik me dis tiens ce jeudi mais bien la
santé moi je suis venu à la maison vin
beaucoup son émission je sais que juppé
fils je ne juge pas les télés et je sais
que tu étais il y avait entre toi et
barthez des choses je si chacun ses
talents d'acteur n'a aucun problème à ce
jeu très bien pour lui c'est très bien
pour nous et moi je suis très heureux de
bras le médecin était aussi
particulièrement doué c'est pas du tout
de la flagornerie pas ce que c'est
c'est pas facile de me faire ce que tu
fais passer à une énergie fiable qui est
que ça mais je connais merci alors oui
j'ai l'énergie de la bêta d'une grande
gentillesse en même temps parce que
c'est vrai tu déconnes tu te fout pas de
la gueule des gens de temps en temps on
a envie parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya
pas à prendre exemple [ __ ] de la
gueule des jours un peu
est ce que tu as déjà fait des émissions
qui était et eroglu à faire alors tu
disais je nous trouve bien meilleur
compte y va c'est que tu es comptables
non je les fais pas tu ne fais pas tu
fais plus trop de télé comme je fais
plus rien ouais t'as pas besoin
même les films
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça tombe bien avec cas madame cela film
qui va sortir s'appelle mdr oui parce
qu'il y avait dedans il y avait deux
prêts prévost jean luc bideau melaine de
montjoux enfin que deco vidic et puis
j'aime beaucoup qui vaut 600 salariés
c'est un garçon qui a qu'à une belle
énergie toute la famille et puis monte
ça ensemble ils à ses copains tennisman
moi je connais pas grand chose au tennis
je connais la balle la balle et il m'a
dit mais non je trouve que c'est bien
quand on a des gens comme ça j'ai fait
un autre
un autre film mais dont je me souviens
plus c'est vrai que comme je n'apprends
plus aucun texte c'est que j'ai une
oreillette
ouais j'ai de réelles c'est tellement
plus simple tu lis les scénarios avons
pas du tout et c'est n'a rien ou pas je
vais non je lis les scénarios merde je
m'intéresse mais tu as le travail des si
je retiens mais j'ai su eux c'est ta
toujours des mecs alors moi je leur dit
le texte
tu as des acteurs qui veulent je suis
recentré d'abord yeux qui attend la
liste d'andré de faire je le fais je
fais boris blank
moi je comprends aussi et il ya des mecs
qui devrait être impressionné de jouer
avec moi tu me dis je dois jouer une
scène avec gérard depardieu joue comme
ça non france lui donc je je je
non au contraire je pense que les gens
ils aiment bien parce que je voulais
regarder l écoute puis je ne les juge
pas pays prennent leur temps puis il ya
tout le temps c'est pas la peine de te
cette scène est minuté avons 30 secondes
ce que tu encore des rêves dans le
cinéma des mecs avec qui tu as pas
tourné avec ita non mais non on voit
tout mais tant pis s'il est mal existe
de moins en moins ce qui est bien céder
les plateformes jeu non c'est un rêve et
une chose que je vais faire je pense
c'est de l'animation c'est un peu comme
la bande dessinée des 500 dans les
pattes de télé parce que si tu cherches
un producteur je peux en être non non
pas d'un des oiseaux et des relations
des films d'animation louis fait vieux
sapins cinq ans dans les 32
ado que ça j'ai trouvé ça très bien on
va se promener l'otiv g dire mes
réflexions même adopté après les faits
on s'accroche à son meilleur souvenir
avec un acteur c'est qu'il actait un kit
a préféré tourner à j'ai beaucoup à
planteurs oui des kids les premiers
comme un jésus mots clés ou richard que
j'ai deux mots canine est définitif et
oui mais vraiment il y avait des acteurs
ans a comme le gaba comme mêmes notes de
long était un peu un peu un peu un peu
moins aller bien prendre un bain de
foule
là je me suis bien amusé avec ton père
avec son fils avec haïti quand on perd
aussi totalement investi dans son rôle
avec l'aviron ne la fais marcher à bord
il était tellement content et puis après
il y avait aussi son grand père à
wimereux montage entre d'effleurer
maintenant d'asus
alors là je le vois tu étais classe
franchement merci
il ya eu des tas pas mal changé de bouc
moi je suis je me suis intéressé à
technique regardons en 74
franchement qui tu étais hyper beau
gosse moi je te kiffe et de ouf et cher
à l'époque je venais de naître voilà les
pelotes clément deux là oui à cette
époque gerra s'était tu devais mais tu
devais faire tomber grave les meufs non
parce que je ne percevais papier moi je
me mets pas tellement c'est vrai nom
diffusée mais trop peu et bachir après
tu as eu un thé un autre regard alors là
c'est tim thomas morzini leur inspecteur
la bavure mais la tête était à bord
s'est dit oui c'est c'est eh non il
avait un peu peur des fois quand c'est
michel away we michel oui c'est vrai
michel colucci dit coluche c'est
pourquoi il faut quand il tournait rien
avait un peu peur parce qu'il y avait
cette espèce de chaussures des délais
ligne les défenses les shows et tous les
mois je n'aimais pas trop ça non plus ah
c'est ça il y avait des marques fr mail
envoyé puise puis c'est pas il parlait
parfois il avait une île parler aux gens
assez assez violemment parfois cyrano
après regarde les magnifiques il permet
d'enrichir à dos et un texte
exceptionnel tu sais tu dis les mots
n'importe quel même mauvais acteur
suffit que ne pas penser de dire
simplement juste les la chose est bien
sympa mais bon quand tu lui dis toi
c'est pas pareil un way you lie alors
après moi je sais cette ça c'était
magnifique en 96 des soins dalmatiens
c'est un autre c'est à gloser c'était
des copains si tu veux te mettais en
scène et l'opérateur de 14 192 we can be
done c'est vrai et c'est très très bien
il y avait plusieurs faisaient adored à
la glenn close qui était très théâtral
il y avait des costumes là-dessus ap
démentent ça c'est un gros film et puis
moi bien sûr yahia stericsson et obélix
tu vas pas le faire le prochain novelli
que non non parce qu'il se réfère aux
biens non pas du tout pas du tout ouais
là le petit vieux canet m'appelle dont
j'aimais pas trouvé qu'il avait fait
réaliser maintenant il là qu'il a fait
m'appeler et me dit il fallait que cette
pub dit oui je suis au courant que tu
vas faire astérix est très bien mais je
n'ai pas le monopole de bd expliqué
uderzo avait dit tant que je serai
vivant là il était parti en flèche des
vies mais non je ne vois aucun la
cohésion et tu as choisi qui est me
disent j'ai mon copain qu'elle fait
beaucoup d'entrées avec eux legrand bat
le bain et ce avec le grand bain je suis
c'est très bien si vous êtes habillé en
plus n'a rien j vous allez le faire en
chine presque franchi le pas gagné
[Rires]
notre époque où vous avez eu un
précédent avec monsieur besson
bien sûr et le chinois va quand même
mettre des américains y poser j'ai
jamais vu des hommes d'affaires pareil
ouais je suis allé beaucoup j'étais avec
ses gym ping à shaolin quand même oui je
médite et un monastère de kung fu
souvent les gens qui sont là bas il ya
une espèce de plats de colonies de juin
n'a pas rigolé quand même avant s'il
cherchait on vous reçoit gérard
maintenant heureux ou pas au moins oui
waterway puisque maintenant je voyage un
peu par mignot a remarqué que les
français y passent tous toi tu n en fait
pas y passent tous non parce que la gt
il n'ya pas il ya trois jours dans un
poste de police avait su y faire peur
parce que je sais que c'est pas ça tu
sais quoi
c'est quoi l'histoire du servette était
en train de manger un bon couscous
moulin bleu du maine
je sais toujours été mon petit saïd
cedac là ça me travaille là je fais je
fais comme tout temps chaque fois je
vais là-bas ouais j'étais avec la dalle
à l'homme script de andré téchiné et à
dia le patin de la tête c'est bien le
père de copia puis je fais mon demi tour
messieurs en la ligne blanche a créé la
voiture et rouge jeudi jc pas vrai alors
là ils reconnaissent les dix poids dans
la balance le casque imai
il faut souffler le même vous avez vu ce
que vous avez fait si oui je fais
toujours forte mais il ya le feu belge
il n'y avait personne ne veut pas
m'amuser à passer devant une bagnole qui
va m'écraser j'ai pas la souplesse
d'avant donc à la fois soufflé à ma
grande surprise j'avais 0,29
ouais et la c-zéro 25 matches mais oui
mais ça ne savais pas
ces patates avec sa part 0 20 c'est une
salade très vite et que je fais ça l'a
miné pour la santé bien sûr et donc oui
donc ils te disent oui il disposerait en
vain j'ai dit donnez moi un autre estime
être éthylotests l'éthylotest
alors on va dans le sens où il y avait
un jeune tunisien très sympathique des
des flics impeccable gentil il y avait
deux russes classées et gavanon ce qui
est dit est là et y avait deux russes et
opal j'ai dit oui jeudi met donc on
parle comme ça j'aime beaucoup la russie
je mets tous à son commissariat tout ça
au commissariat une soirée au
commissariat des tanks mais un peu comme
gainsbourg faisait aulas fait 2-3 que
ses saillies ensemble frais et donc
c'est ça et donc après je souffle et là
je tombe 0,27 à mozart tiens je reste 10
minutes de plus oui bon mais en fait
beau ils vont dit tu peux pas repartir
on est obligé s'il n'y a pas de problème
quand le garde de scooter sur le
trottoir janvier à quelqu'un de chercher
voilà c'est un moment tarik il arrive
qu'on a mis mon amour lavalard inda mois
et puis dont je vois le lendemain c'est
là où je voulais dire que toi tu tendent
et en sort très bien tu te débrouilles
avec sa magnifique mans parce que ces
[ __ ] de comment ça s'appelle des
milliardaires glapissent et les met pas
des réseaux sociaux
c'est ce qui vient heurter toutes tes
manceau veut plus et je lui en plus
c'est les flip est ce que c'est vrai que
quand tu es bien du tout sur les réseaux
hta pas du tout non mais ce que j'aime
et ce même quand la soul non puisqu'on
avait piétiné de téléphone j'ai un
téléphone chinois huawei que je déteste
apple
c'est vrai que tu déteste tout ce qui
vient des états unis
ah oui bon il paraît qu'on m'a dit on
peut lui servir tout ce que tu veux mais
pas dans leur canapé pas d'américain pas
d'américain arrivée chez american oui le
gentil ricaine sa mère est pas
d'amérique alors non non si si si il
vient de tourner et john malkovich est
amer super pote à toi magnifique moins
batailleur il a fait une tournée avec
moi de motos puissantes sous vide
exemple il en parle là dessus pour aller
voir johnny était aussi avec était parti
très loin
il rejoint c'est quoi cette histoire
avec johnny et john malkovich justement
parce que s'il paraît que tu m'as n'a
pas ce que j'avais des chais pas je suis
arrivé à john malkovich johnny et gérard
depardieu qui est folle oui mais c'est
sur la suis passé devant leur facebook
maintenant j'avais j'arrive à minuit il
y avait des jobs qui était la salle une
jeune très potes étaient là et j'avais
apporté à gros morceau de viande
ouais j'y tiens t'en veux à direct 8 une
coupe des morceaux et je mange comme un
chien ouais mais j'adore la viande crue
alors comment une audi ski je ne
comprends pas après votre support amis
c'est seulement quand même ça que je dis
mot serial si on veut pas mes moustaches
sûr c'est bon j'y tiens on va les voir
de jolies midi jeannie mais si johnny
hallyday johnny hallyday s'est dit oui
c'est un chanteur ils adorent ils
voudraient connaître
on va y aller ouais et je le monte sur
la moto fuchsia la rêveuse groupe fotso
et puis méchaal ait pas l'adresse
[Rires]
l'huile était derrière
et voilà en été on a fait deux trois
tours sur auteurs du beh bordel de merde
allez oust sa rue
j'arrête les gens la rude à wil et
jalila s'il faut entendre john malkovich
raconter ça et b parce que c'était un
homme extraordinairement drôle avec
lequel je faisais rire parce que je
faisais de la direction de figuration
avec dans l'egypte de josée dayan qui
était vraiment le bleu là l oti
brouillard des me dis qu'est-ce qui va
faire et je faisais de la direction de
figuration il y avait un des types
étaient connais pas ce que ça urnes et à
chaque fois et dès que j'en voyais comme
ça je disais n'étant pas dit ce qui tu
dois faire
il a par exemple pu voter dans un bureau
de police
voyage à berck y va ferrer le battre
coville tout ça en anglais parce que la
corse était gêné c'est que ce conflit
dans l'est de bois de de jukebox je suis
dit tu vois pour avoir une contenance tu
prends ton liv est inhalée donc là je
regarde bien tu envoies un autre mais ce
type bouger de ce coup de jeune ouvrier
comme ça zurich est il en train de faire
est là moteur action
j'avais ma john passe et mentent ils
commencent à sauter dans les médias et
bla bla qu'est ce que c'est que cet
abruti
là je regarde je n'en sais rien c'est
moi qui ai mal il savoir si jean 5
tu as connu pratiquement tous les
présidents de la république tu les a
tous connu tu étais proche d'eux c'était
quoi même mitterrand chirac sarkozy en
gt gt proche de sarkozy mais si je
comprenais à peu près ouais j'aime
mitterrand c'est quand même le sait
c'est machiavel c'est le pape mais
j'avais damas pour la pour monsieur
monique lang naples m disait gérard oct
y voit le président maurice ennui c'est
la guerre du golfe à leur bol vîmes
parlait ce qui l'intéressait c'était de
connaître un peu toutes les histoires de
cul des actrices
alors je n'invente est bien sûr merci
rémi serait gagnant n'inventait se
régaler
s'il y avait une complicité et détection
ils n'étaient pas sow est donc là j'ai
longtemps
effectivement j'ai passé de longues lui
dans l'appartement la bad elysées je
veux dire que le très sympathique était
aussi chirac parce que lui même a fait
appeler à la à la mairie de paris et m'a
dit c'est que l'autre qui m'a appelé et
je vais devoir dit gérard j'ai un gros
problème
je ne passe pas de télévision mais tu
passe pas
edit j'ai beaucoup de mal à m'expliquer
une façon je sais quoi dit le dis ce que
tu viens de me dire ah oui tu veux dire
votre cher mais de téléspectateurs je
suis très maladroit quand je parle donc
prêts à vous le dire
voilà c'est l'appui de ceux du coup ça
c'est bien s'est il a été bon a présenté
le missouri oui très beau bateau ils
veulent garder comme ça a bien sûr mais
puel maintenant tu l'as dit rencontrer à
ne jamais jamais il agit peut pas
chercher à 3 contre et il m a téléphoné
de trois fois là quand j'étais aux rats
d'albany d'accord je dis non je profite
trop s'effritera monnaie
c'est trop pour l'instant non c'est moi
tu le sais pas mon monde et je respecte
vocation est tellement difficile à voter
en france on pas vers un bien non je
vais pas voter at a pas voté
j'évoquais en russie oui je veux tu es à
l'ambassade battant comme on dit on vote
on ose dire qui va gagner non non
matelas et il a déjà essayé ces faits
mais pas comme pas comme jules césar lui
s'est fait sa vie après la plante et
tous les 50 mètres
non s'il y avait medvedev un moment non
le medvedev s'est tassée des
arrangements parce que c'est vrai que
c'est compliqué moi je veux pas je
connais pas bien la russie j'adore les
russes 5 j'adore c'est leur littérature
en musique leur culture mais je sais
aussi que c'est pas accès cette api qui
était difficile lourd mais même tolstoï
je pense qu'il a cessé d'écrire à 47 ans
48 ans et il est il s'est tourné vers la
religion et voulait libérer ces les
serbes et les serfs étaient accrochés
dans petit pertes et nous on est mieux
avec toi c'est quoi le pays où tout sens
le mieux le pays où je me sens le mieux
la france craint non non belgique non
non non non j'en suis arrête la belgique
jugeant complètement schizo maintenant
c'est à dire c'est pas pu manger pas fui
là j'ai fait chez qu'un sujet fait
l'autre monsieur le tabou ty hollande
qui nous regardent
non mais il le sait ça soit venu et bien
et me fais avec hérault l'arrêt mais il
me balance
et puis la poutine qui appelle tu penses
il est pas rater à machad l'a bien
mérité venez challah il m'envoie un
afghan star et team qui vous appelez qui
vous allez venez en russie il devient
aussi c'est faisait un peu sport moi
quand j'ai voulu quitter paris a le
maire de cergy pourquoi ce qui m'a fait
l'idiot
la maison fait donc c'est fou non mais
il y avait un grand public en russie
tous et on a fait des ouais je pense que
même via des plus gros films étaient
claude zidi
ensuite bon j'achève on a fait des 150
millions spectateur et non la russie
puis à toutes les autres républiques
relations alors moi je n'ai pas de je
regarde tout simplement j'étais en
ouzbékistan où j'ai fait d'aider des
documentaires la mer d'aral vide et
c'est un glucide en d'ailleurs je sais
khrouchtchev cas vie des saints pour
arroser les gens ousbek et ils ont vidé
tout ça on arrive à faire des
catastrophes mais c'est pas outillés
pour rien poutine au contraire je pense
qu'il a il a essayé de récupérer toutes
les choses que c'est pas mieux que
helsinn delaney de lancer dans ses
multiples est devenu protect poutine
poutine louis-marie beaucoup de bruit
mais pas mais j'en ai je bien sûr se
voit pas tous les jours et en surprises
j'ai pu savoir c'est que les des
journalistes et des choses pense que
c'est un amour s'il est certainement moi
j'ai jamais un monstre devant moi
d'accord mais le peuple russe a et est
très heureux très heureux
on peut pas dire ça mais le partout où
je suis allé ce que j'habite à
novossibirsk irkoutsk sibérie
non je peux pas beau certainement qu'il
ya des choses qui sont insupportables et
je ne les vois pas je les ai pas vus
vient en avant je ne comprends pas tout
ce que les gens disent le ballon lui
voilà tu vas chanter j'ai rallongé ton
spectacle sur barbara ou est
exceptionnel on va faire au théâtre des
champs elysées exceptionnel mais c'est
tout quoi au théâtre des champs elysées
après sentent ailleurs dans le monde et
je te tiens un beau jour il m'a dit ou
peut-être une
près d'un lac je me suis je m'étais
endormi quand soudain sco soudain quand
soudain leur demande encore et le ciel
voilà alors de nulle part surgit un âne
et le noir
lentement les ados du bruit voilà
lentement badabing c'est bien mais faut
que tu chantes h ou bien contenu alors
j'ai morte à un ami qui est aussi un ami
un ami commun c'est yann moix
ah oui yann moix et puis j'aime beaucoup
qui là on est allé voir un autre copain
dictateur comme dirait mes copains les
journalistes me ali oui vous êtes les
idées c'est pareil et les surprenants
corée du nord ait encore dans l'oeil du
nord oui vous êtes on connait c'est à
dire que l'autre pays qui ressemble plus
au pays soviétiques et communistes c'est
lukashenko l'agriculteur cette passion
pour les dictateurs mais c'est plein je
n'ai pas de passer au volet végétation
pour la terre d'accord là la biélorussie
tas j'y suis allé la première fois pour
regarder des tracteurs français membres
à faire là bas ils sont très costauds
matador un peu bah oui j'adore les
tracteurs et dans les machines
je n'ai pas forcément de patio pour
dictateurs mais je suis curieux et c'est
vrai que quand tu vas à celle où qu'a
fait ricco c'est effectivement l'union
soviétique de d'avant des menteurs des
débuts bien m
tout çà et là j'ai vu un autre petit
rachat n beaucoup oui vraiment tu sais
que je t'aime énormément
oui je suis pas sûr qu'on parte en
vacances ensemble l'année prochaine tu
me tiens tu me compare je peux tu as
menée dans une destination c'est que je
kifferais partir en vacances etc temps
mais j'ai su zadeh en tunisie aussi où
j'aime beaucoup mais quand tu es là tu
si c'est moi la tunise latvérie ce que
tu veux qu'on parle voyage c'est
l'impression chara non alors j'aimerais
qu'on teste l'amitié de yann moix à ton
égard
oui donc on va appeler yann moix on va
essayer de le piéger tuvalu dire que tu
es en galère parce que tu t'es fait
choper par ton voisin parce que tu a
défoncé sa voiture avec son scooter ou
bien encore tu t'es fait choper avec le
scooter
donc on est au commissariat je jouerai
une fois de plus le commissaire
divisionnaire blanchard tu vas voir
gérard je suis un acteur hors pair
là tu as joué avec les plus grands là ça
va te faire tout drôle
annoncé très bien allez c'est parti on
n'a pas les avoirs extérieurs
on est en direct bien sûr mais cette
année c'est fou même le téléphone oui
allô allô allô oui oui mais yann oui
bonjour à gérard comment vas tu ben ça
va et war elle est appelée justement jal
est appelé ce matin là bas j'étais
encore là se bat à non mais je vais
partir bientôt tuer ou à l'abattoir
chercher à 9h la shema real droit où il
exagéré quand il se moque des médecins
de l'époque les hauts dignitaires
on peut c'est sans fin cette histoire on
est là on va voir le procès de charlie
ben ça va à monsieur avec cyril
moi c'était comme un héros n'ont rien tu
veux bien mais parce que mona suis à
l'as tu sais que les flics m'ont chopé
il ya vendredi alors que j'avais 0,27
d'anatole mer 29 après vingt-sept et
après je suis allé au passé de 27 je
pensais qu'on était toujours à 0,50 et
où la météo la bine la chine deux rôles
commissariat j'ai envie de défoncer dans
l'inspecteur blanc battu la voilà est-ce
que tu peux dire ce qu'on doit être
faire une blague mais c'est raté la
blague c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
m
c'est bien mais je t'assure il dit il
est très mauvais acteurs je me dis je
vais pas le foot dans une difficulté me
gérard tu m'as sauvé la vie je voudrais
qu'on applaudisse très fort gérard
depardieu est ce que tu as appris qu'un
nul hier 130 m mais en face de toi j'ai
en face de toi jean valjean en face de
toi balzac
tu as en face de toi cyrano de bergerac
tu as en face de toi christophe colomb
tu refais toi obélix t'arrêtes tu as en
face de toi dans tôt quand on les attend
et on a monté la tête au peuple en vaut
la peine
et donc je crois que gérard est la seule
personne qui puisse allier le génie
artistique et le génie humain et les
deux ans une constante c'est pas la
modestie les payes ton modeste si
l'humidité
bravo plein mois
mais pour pour la fin de plus mon poste
que je pas dit tout de suite allé
rejoindre mes équipes pourra prendre ou
à laisser en direct bien sûr gérard ce
que tu as un dernier mot à nous dire
parce que c'est toi le premier invité ce
soir j'étais très très heureux tout vent
j'aurais pu discuter avec toi encore des
heures je te je vous souhaite à tous une
très bonne année suivant sinon ce que
vos amis vont nous faire le pardon des
politiques le permet vous c'est pas
tellement ça je parle des réseaux
sociaux par deux de toutes les bonnes
surprises parle de ton père va savoir
ouverte pour jean-pierre cette façon
c'est excitant
tu es dans un endroit formidable qui
était lancé un studio de cinéma où j'ai
fait trois quatre films avec le vieux
gaba et de l'eau puis plein d'autres
c'est très bien ton émission est
extrêmement sympathique et drôle tu as
passé un bon moment avec moi j'ai très
bien
ben moi aussi et tu reviendras voir
couture j'espère merci beaucoup et j'ai
refait un jeune tout leur merci gérard
depardieu